beth catch your breath have you got your
battery left on your phone i've got my
phone's running out repetitive strength
running out of juice no no talk to me
you've been trying to gauge opinion from
those close to the prime minister what's
being said do you just want to finish
that message yeah no i'm just checking
i'm just checking uh what's moving
because as we've just seen
we've had now 27 resignations
five ministers resigning in one blow uh
quickly um followed by
another uh minister
i mean it is now really in free fall and
actually when that letter of five came
through i was on the phone to a cabinet
minister having a discussion about what
they thought was uh going on and they
were trying to put quite a positive spin
on uh
boris johnson's predicament and and that
that resignation of five cabinet
ministers led this person to say to me i
really can't see a positive outcome i
subsequently spoken to another cabinet
minister again a loyalist who just said
to me the game's up this is not
survivable i can't see the pm last in
the day and those suggesting he stays on
are not doing him any favors i'm in the
trenches with him but we're outgunned
outmaneuvered and out of ammunition
there are also reports broken and
exclusive by john stevens at the daily
mail
that michael gove has also
privately said to the prime minister he
thinks it's time he should go but i
should stress that michael gove has not
resigned
and we're just trying to get that
confirmed but reports uh from john
stevens it's his exclusive um that
michael gove has also told the prime
minister uh his times his team certainly
aren't denying that to me
at the moment because he wasn't in the
house today was he and he had his house
although i understand he was
actually
um
i do understand that he was actually
helping with pmq prep earlier today okay
so there you go but look this is
extremely fast moving the prime minister
is meant to be up at the lays on
committee um at 3 pm so in just over 15
minutes
but the 22 committee
are poised to meet are they going to try
and change the rules today to try and
force that vote but it now feels like
the avalanche of resignations are just
making the position of boris johnson
untenable whatever he wants to do and it
might be that in the end he doesn't
leave
of his own volition and he is forced out
by a confidence vote um but this
happened to teresa men i remember she
had a confidence vote in her she
survived the vote and then six months
later graham brady who heads the 22 back
bench committee tapped her on the
shoulder and said you have lost the
support of the party and she
by convention
resigned of her own accord and now the
question is what does boris johnson do
now the events are completely out of his
control his party is ungovernable
whatever he decides to do and so really
now i would say
we said last night on the news the
question now is moving not to can he
survive but how long will he survive
and that process over the past 12 hours
has accelerated very very rapidly